hallo leute ich jetzt wieder eure mal
wanne und wir kommen zu einer neuen
folge wie schmeckt und leute machen wir
einen sms app cache cryptic und die
ganze folge werde ich bleiben werde egal
wie sehr ich ja mehr videos liebe ich
glaube ich könnte niemals vor einer
kamera so crazy flüstern - auch heute
aufpassen weil bei meinem letzten video
oder hat die aus und bisschen befreit
und so glaubte mir nicht aber im
reallife zieht das okay aus sieht cool
aus wenn ich die sonne aber auf der
kamera sehe sehe ich nur so ein kern
speckigen und ein paar leute mir
aufgeschrieben
pauli sagte bauch aber das ist natürlich
heute gar nicht thema sondern wir machen
einen smr rainbow crêpes cache es ist
jetzt nicht wirklich ein ass im ergriff
cache also diesen kuchen oder diese
torte gibt es glaube ich auch einfach so
ohne als mr
aber youtube hat monate zeit immer
wieder ein video vorgeschlagen von
verschiedenen leuten in dem sie hat
diesen kraft cache essen diesem rainbow
magica kräfte und ich weiß nicht was
mich an diesem crêpes cache so
fasziniert aber er ist so mainzer schirm
sorry mein sonst wäre gerade fast vom
balkon gesprungen ich habe ihn jetzt mal
zu gemacht wo war ich
ich weiß jetzt nicht was mich an diesem
eher kräftig videos so fasziniert ich
glaube es ist dieses geräusch was dieser
kräfte macht dieses matschige
ich kann es nicht beschreiben aber auf
jeden fall ist es super star des feigen
für mich also eher kritisch richtig
singles bei und deswegen wollte ich
unbedingt mal ausprobieren weil ja auch
super lecker aussieht und passend zum
thema natürlich mein look
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit sogar lidschatten denn echt
bananabay queen intro geschafft die
zubereitung ist eigentlich ganz einfach
wir müssen viele krebs machen in vielen
farben und mit sahne bestreichen falls
sie das video von der peter sondern
findet heute schon gesehen habt hier ist
übrigens der link dann wisst ihr dass
ich eigentlich schon profi boxer
man könnte sagen experten aber ich heute
dass wir heute noch ein bisschen
steigern und deshalb habe ich ein crêpe
maker gekauft den link zu dem crash
make-up wir natürlich unten in der video
beschreibung falls idee mit meinem
amazon appelliert liegen kaufen wollte
und mich in meiner arbeit unterstützen
möchte danke wir brauchen ein typisches
crêpes rezept französische krebs
natürlich wollen wir das original apple
sein feier mich und wo der krebs zu
machen ist wirklich das einfachste auf
der welt wächst gramm mehl
jetzt kommen drei prisen salz 123 600
milliliter milch sechs eier wird er ist
schwer
wisst ihr was ich schade finde dass so
viele leute an dass in ihrer videos
nicht mögen ich finde arten die nicht
super entspannt 30
wenn leute ganz leise sprechen und
flüstern ich weiß nich 200 mit so vielen
bruchs problem haben und es wird nicht
lustig dass du es entweder so liebt oder
hasst
[Applaus]
das früher für mich ein bisschen zucker
hinzu das kann jetzt in die mikrowelle
huhu und jetzt beim rühren nach und nach
das wasser und die butter hinzufügen
machen wir kein problem
sie müssen und es zeit brauchen
ich habe hier einmal so ein netz wo ich
das dann so rauth league damit dass
zukünftig abkühlen kann
und hier wird dann gelagert ich mache
ist ein bombenkrieg schnitt so und jetzt
warten wir kurz und verstreichen das
okay wäre definitiv zu wenig um den ich
schon mal besser aus wie komplex
[Musik]
scheiße
sein argument sie kriegen gleichen club
[Musik]
die ferne war gleich einfach zu heiß
betriebes ahlmann lässt jetzt wohl auf
der einen seite länger braucht und es
dann halt kurz und das ist erst dann
muss mir jetzt entfernen zum einfärben
braucht ihr noch mal verdammt jede
schüssel die ihr in eurem haushalt
gefunden habt 1234
[Musik]
wir haben ein zwei drei vier fünf töpfe
und 4 x 4 binger gehen
das heißt ja 20 ja 20 schichten sind
schon gewundert schlichten wäre
natürlich besser geschichten kennt
ich habe das fenster aufgemacht weil es
so warm hier drin wurde es tut mir leid
hintergrundgeräusche hört wird es bei
ihm an
[Musik]
ok wird schon das wird schon
eine viel zu lange zeit später was wir
jetzt zum fertigmachen dieses skript
kuchens brauchen ist eine leckere sahne
creme und deshalb brauchen wir jetzt so
was für ein glück dass sich seine hier
habe ich möchte aber die sahne creme ein
bisschen finden war ich nur sagen etwas
langweilig finde deshalb macht noch
weiße schokolade rein zitrone und bruder
zuerst müssen wir unsere schokolade
schmeckt natürlich muss man auch die
weiße schokolade probieren
das heiße wasser sei jetzt die schultern
schmerzen
viel spaß er schaut das schönste viele
zeiten passiert wenn ihr ein wasserbad
macht weil keine wasser in die schublade
gelangen wir lassen uns nicht aus der
ruhe bringen macht jetzt geschlagen
wurde
in ungedüngte bagger kommt jetzt die
beide spiele
[Musik]
das riecht so gut
und diesen weg werden wir jetzt
zerstören mit
[Musik]
das ist ja lustig
man nehme einen krippen blick genau zu
sein klagt jetzt einfach streichen
[Musik]
ich bin ich hab keine butter primär ich
muss jetzt irgendwie buttercreme
organisieren machen tun ok damit die
normale mutter krimis verlassen hat
werde ich eine mango creme machen
[Musik]
und da kommt jetzt unsere moral das
letzte puzzlestück von unserem kredit
soll ich schneide ich einfach
[Musik]
und hier ist sie unsere 20 schichten
rainbow torte mit marco krämer halbwaise
sprache und sperling oben drauf ich sage
mal so spontan kann ich gibt es auch in
seinem am anfang bin ich der größte
unten völlig übertrieben und stellen uns
natürlich wieder das allerwichtigste
frage wie schmeckt wie kuchen mit sahne
und so absolut lecker ich hoffe
natürlich wie immer hat die folge
gefallen auch wenn es dieses mal ein
bisschen wieder chaotisch war und es so
auf wie dadurch nichts hinkriegen würde
wir sehen uns das nächste mal doch nach
oben
hier sind zwei videos und ich jetzt
essen